the bell's
already been wrong
and they've heard it
but in the dark among the stars
the god is dead
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new justice league
snyder cut teaser trailer video zack
snyder has been dropping a bunch of new
footage for the big panel that's
happening tomorrow so we'll break it all
down there are a ton of brand new scenes
i'll be doing videos for all the big dc
movie trailers that they drop this
weekend so be sure to subscribe to get
all those videos i'll do a special
giveaway as part of those too
dc sent me this giant mystery box is
part of dc
fandom so i'll open this later on my
social media accounts so just look out
for that separately later today
but just going down the list here the
new footage starting with number five it
starts with a very different version of
batman going to recruit aquaman we see
him handing aquaman his bruce wayne
business card like batman carries around
business cards
this version of the scene in the movie
is way more hardcore
than the one in the theatrical cut like
there's still a scene of him going to
recruit aquaman in the theatrical cut
but the zack snyder version is
very very different you will probably
remember they included a bunch of that
zack snyder footage in the original
justice league trailers from a couple
years ago so we've actually seen
some versions of this scene before there
was also that special behind the scenes
video that zack snyder released back at
comic con 2016 that had a lot of this
footage in that too
the one in the snyder cut is a much
longer version of the scene that plays
out and
aquaman almost rips batman in half he's
so aggressively not
into joining his special quote-unquote
new superhero club that he's putting
together
initially when you meet aquaman during
the snyder cut he's way more standoffish
he really doesn't want to have anything
to do with humanity
other than the people that he's
protecting in this town and on the other
side of things he doesn't want to have
anything to do with the atlanteans
because they don't like him either
there's a big subplot storyline for
aquaman's character in the snyder cut
that he's adding back in
way more set up for his character before
the aquaman movie that gives you a lot
more context for his relationship with
atlantis in a bunch more atlantis mira
and even
a big volco scene that's right willem
dafoe filmed a bunch of footage for
justice league as
vulco they just wound up hitting the
cutting room floor because they deleted
a bunch of storylines to get the film
down to two hour run time i don't know
if any of that footage is going to be in
the full justice league trailer the zack
snyder drops tomorrow but the volco
stuff was basically him
just having similar conversations that
they had during the aquaman movie sort
of giving you more backstory on their
relationship and what aquaman was like
growing up
why the atlanteans don't want to have
anything to do with them even though he
has this responsibility to protect them
because he's the heir apparent
then a much longer version of these
scenes with mira that you saw during the
theatrical cut sort of explaining their
relationship
because she actually had a pre-existing
relationship with aquaman's mother
so she has sort of ties to him even
though they're not really romantically
involved with each other at this point
in the story
james wan who's directing aquaman 2 is
going to be doing a panel for that at dc
fandom but they haven't started filming
that yet so i don't know if he's going
to show off any concept art i think he's
going to explain a little bit about
where the story is headed in aquaman 2
outside of black manta just becoming the
main villain
then number 4 there's another cyborg
scene in star labs with the flash
looking like he's having trouble
functioning properly like he's just
trying to get his bearings this is
probably from later in the movie because
zack snyder did film an origin story for
cyborg that got deleted from the
theatrical cut
that's what all these football scenes
are from this is from before he fused
with the mother box that all happened
before the events of batman v superman
so the football scenes in justice league
are flashbacks to a couple years ago in
context in the timeline but he only
became cyborg a little while ago it
hasn't been that long
it's kind of this subplot of his arc
during justice league he still doesn't
fully understand his powers and as the
film goes along he learns more and more
about his connection to the mother boxes
about darkseid
apocalypse so we might even see some
references to that batman v superman
background scene of his father studying
him as he gets fused with the mother box
in the snyder cut
that was from that footage that was on
lex luthor's hard drive the scene of the
burning car flying at the police officer
near the kryptonian ship is another
cyborg scene of him after he's become
cyborg and present-day saving the cop
just him being a hero
you probably remember there was a
version of that scene that also appeared
in some of the trailers
i believe it happens sometime close to
when they get ready to fight superman in
that big resurrection scene
if you saw any of the deleted scenes
that leaked out after the movie came out
in theaters a couple of years ago
most of those were actually cyborg
scenes because of all the characters in
the movie
cyborg's scenes were cut out the most
zack snyder made this
big deal in his big justice con panel
about the story line for cyborg and the
snyder got being
very very different he said that cyborg
was an important character in his
version of the movie because he's
supposed to be this core member the
heart of the justice league who helps
bring the team together initially
and as you saw during the theatrical cut
we didn't see any of that
it doesn't seem like that's going on
because he's barely in that version of
the movie to begin with and it almost
seems like in that version wonder woman
has to drag him along kicking and
screaming to join the team
a lot of questions about how the snyder
cut is just going to be a different
version of the theatrical cut is
actually going to be a completely
different movie i still think there's
going to be a lot of confusion about
that until they release a bunch more
footage and you see a bunch of those new
scenes
then number three there's a scene of the
flash running that actually looks very
similar to the scene of him running
through the kryptonian ship when they
were resurrecting superman
but the background of the landscape here
makes it look like it's happening during
that big final battle in the movie
against steppenwolf
i think part of the reason why a lot of
his running scenes look similar is
because
all of ezra miller's running scenes were
done on green screen on this giant
treadmill
so anytime he runs in the movie even
when it's in different scenes
he looks very similar like they're
reusing footage even though they're not
they just use this giant treadmill like
grant gustin used to use
on the flash tv show when he was running
the flash tv show has actually changed
the way they do their running scenes a
little differently
but overall if there's something that i
wish they improved for the flash movie
talking about ezra miller's flash
it would be the way he looks when he's
running they won't be filming that movie
for a while and i know they just made
the big
announcement about ben affleck coming
back as batman during that movie so i'll
address that at the end of the video too
but number two then there's the same
scene of wonder woman cyborg and aquaman
inside steppenwolf's base dropping down
this was in all the early trailers when
zack snyder was still on the movie so
this scene probably looks familiar
one of the things you'll notice though
is that even though a lot of these zack
snyder scenes that he's been teasing
stayed in later trailers after joss
whedon took over the movie
what they started to do in those later
versions of the trailers is start to
recolor the movie so that it looked like
the weeding cut
they changed the aspect ratio of the
movie too so in the theatrical cut
that's why all these scenes look like
they're happening during the day but in
the zack snyder footage it looks like
they're happening at night
but zack snyder did this big explainer
back at his justice league comic con
panel where he explained that he filmed
the entire movie or his version of the
movie in true
imax aspect ratio which is closer to 4x9
which looks letterbox
he did say that at some point there was
always the hope that
maybe they could do a limited theatrical
imax release but no idea when that could
happen or if warner brothers would ever
want to do it
because right now they're only releasing
the justice league snyder cut on hbo max
next year
the number one there's this new version
of the superman resurrection scene where
he fights the rest of the justice league
notice again how even though it seems
similar to the theatrical cut
fight that he has with the justice
league it's actually happening at night
in the snyder cut so it looks
very different in the scene itself
obviously in the snyder cut is much
longer than the version of the
theatrical cut remember the snyder cut
is going to be over four hours long so
that includes
longer versions of scenes and just
complete subplots for characters during
the movie that were cut out like i talk
about how they killed
cyborg's storyline during the movie for
the theatrical cut
just recently when zack snyder was
releasing this footage he was also
making fun of
part of the theatrical version of this
scene too he was joking about the do you
bleed scene where superman is getting
ready to rip batman apart
so i'm assuming that means that was a
joss whedon line of dialogue that they
added in the reshoots
so real helpful guide for the footage
that was joss whedon's versus the
footage that was zack snyder's in the
original theatrical cut
is that anytime you see superman with
the weird-looking mustache removal
special effects
that's all from the joss whedon reshoots
anytime you see superman looking
normal like this scene here no special
effects on henry cavill's face he looks
totally normal
that's all zack snyder footage there's
going to be a bunch of big trailers that
they release tomorrow so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see all those videos when i post
them
i'll just do videos for as many things
as i can and anything i don't get to
saturday i'll just do videos for later
in the week i just did a big video about
ben affleck coming back
in the flash movie as bruce wayne for
some flashpoint scenes
click here to learn what's going on with
that and click here for my brand new
wonder woman 1984
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
i'll see you guys tonight
you